[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
hallo da sind wir wieder Tatort
Deutschland der tägliche truecrime
Podcast mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und
ich bin Toni Heyer heute springen wir
ohne lang zu schnacken direkt an ein
Tatort in der Nähe des Dortmunder
Stadtteils Siegburg ein Abend im Mai
[Musik]
ein Golf parkt an einer verlassenen
Straße in der Nähe eines Waldstücks die
Insassen sprechen leise polnisch
miteinander da kommen sie sagt einer von
ihnen als ein weiteres Auto ein Stück
hinter ihnen anhält
ein Mann steigt aus und kommt auf den
Wagen der Polen zu sie warten der
Beifahrer kurbelt die Schale herunter
er hat nicht vorauszusteigen das Geld
kann ihm der Mann auch durch das Fenster
reichen doch statt einer Tüte voller
Geldscheine lässt der Mann etwas anderes
in den Fußraum des Wagens fallen wo es
mit einem dumpfen Geräusch aufschlägt
der Mann vor dem Auto Fenster dreht sich
um und rennt zurück als der verwirrte
Beifahrer bemerkt was zu seinen Füßen
liegt ist es zu spät
eine Handgranate explodiert und reißt
ihm die Unterschenkel weg
einer der drei ist sofort tot der
Beifahrer lebt noch und versucht sich
aus dem brennenden Wagen zu befreien
doch da sind die Attentäter schon zurück
und schießen ihm mit einer Schrotflinte
in den Rücken dann rennen sie erneut zu
ihrem Wagen steigen ein und rasenlos der
dritte Insasse des brennenden Autos kann
entkommen er schleppt sich schwer
verletzt in den nahegelegenen Wald
während die Angreifer an ihm
vorbeifahren und mit Schrotflinten
erst als er das Blaulicht eines
Polizeiwagens sieht kommt er mit
erhobenen Händen aus seinem verstecken
er hat überlebt und kann einen der Täter
beim Namen nennen
Norman Volker Franz
[Musik]
Alter Handgranaten pumpguns ist das hier
wirklich noch Tatort Deutschland oder in
was für einem krassen Film sind wir hier
gelandet bitte eine Handgranate das ist
schon das ist wirklich crazy wer ist
dieser Normen Volker Franz und was hat
ihn an diesem Punkt gebracht Norman
Volker Franz wird am 30 januar 1970 in
Arnsberg geboren wächst auf in Dortmund
in der Nordstadt in der Nähe des
borsigplatzes die Gegend geht als
sozialer Brennpunkt mit hoher
Arbeitslosigkeit viel Armut und
Kriminalität
sein Vater stirbt als er noch ein Kind
ist
Norman ist ein ehrgeiziger junge nach
der Schule machte eine Lehre zum
Elektriker nach der Ausbildung geht er
ans Dortmunder Westfalen Kolleg um das
Abitur nachzuholen seine Lehrer erinnern
sich an einen guten und engagierten
Schüler er hat das Zeug auf ganz
normalem ehrlichen wegkarriere zu machen
aber das reicht ihm nicht kurz vor dem
Prüfungen zum Abitur taucht er nicht
mehr zum Unterricht auf er will jetzt
Geld haben er will schnelle Autos fahren
und erholt sich was er will schon in
dieser Zeit fährt er einen dicken BMW
der über 100.000 Mal kostet Norman Franz
ist längst kriminell geworden und
schickt sich an die Dortmunder Unterwelt
aufzumischen erschließt sich einer Gang
rund um Bankenchef Christian K an
zeitweise gehören um die 30 Männer dazu
sie überfallen Banken schmuggeln
Zigaretten handeln mit Waffen und haben
Kontakte ins zuhältermilieu
die Mitglieder der Bande beziehen
Sozialhilfe oder gehen schlecht
bezahlten Jobs nach aber trotzdem leben
sie auf großem Fuß und fahren schneller
Autos
1993 lernt er Sandra kennen die damals
16-Jährige ist Joy und hat wenig
Selbstbewusstsein umso mehr beeindruckt
sie dieser intelligente charmante Mann
und vielleicht auch sein Geld von dem er
mehr als genug zu haben scheint die
beiden werden ein Paar und Normen wird
zur wichtigsten Bezugsperson in ihrem
Leben in einem Interview für Achtung
Ahnung sagt sie er war eigentlich immer
lieb und nett zu mir hat mir auch das
Gefühl gegeben dass ich wichtig für ihn
bin wenn ich früher ein bisschen stärker
gewesen wäre hätte ich einfach auf den
Tisch hauen müssen und sagen müssen nein
das mache ich nicht das will ich nicht
so wie ich das heute auch sagen würde
aber früher habe ich es einfach nicht
gemacht
Norman Franz zeigt dir eines Tages eine
Kiste mit Waffen
Pistolen und eine Handgranate sie weiß
womit sie es zu tun hat aber sie weiß
noch nicht mit wem sie es zu tun hat
einem Mann der keines Kumpel kennt und
auch vom Mord nicht zurückschreckt
1995 befindet sich die Bande um
Christian K in einem heftigen
Konkurrenzkampf mit polnischen
zigarettenschmucklern die Polen Wissen
von einem Bankraub der Bande und drohen
Christian K in und seine Truppe
auffliegen zu lassen wenn er ihn nicht
ein schweige Geld zahlt zum Schein geht
Christian K darauf ein doch statt mit
Geld schickt er Norman Franz und zwei
seiner Kumpane mit einer Handgranate und
Schrotflinten zum vereinbarten
Übergabeort
und damit sind wir wieder an jenem
schrecklichen Tag im Mai 1995 an dem
zwei Menschen sterben und an dem ein
Überlebender des Attentats der Polizei
den Namen von Normen Volker Franz nennt
der ist unter dessen auf der Flucht
zusammen mit Sandra D zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nur weiß dass etwas
Schreckliches geschehen sein muss aber
noch keine Ahnung hat dass sie mit einem
Doppelmörder im Auto sitzt das Ziel ist
Portugal doch nach zwei Monaten kehren
sie aus Geldmangel nach Deutschland
zurück und schnell sind ihm die Fahnder
auf der Spur in der Fußgängerzone von
Osnabrück endet Norman Volker Franz
kriminelle Karriere
sagen wir eher so die Verhaftung ist ein
Karriereknick im März 1996 wird Norman
Franz wegen Mordes zu lebenslanger Haft
verurteilt das Gericht erkennt eine
besondere Schwere der Schuld Norman
Franz soll die ganzen 20 Jahre absetzen
das beginnt aber gleich mal ungewöhnlich
und zwar mit einer Hochzeit im Mai
desselben Jahres heiratet er im
Gefängnis
Hochzeit im Knast Mirko das klingt jetzt
nicht so nach einer tollen Party
eher nach einer schlechten Vorabendserie
aber aus Sandra wird Sandra Franz seine
Ehefrau auf die Flitterwochen müssen sie
aus offensichtlichen Gründen verzichten
aber das Paar hat fest vor Sie sobald
wie möglich nachzuholen Sandra Franz die
frischgebackene Ehefrau wird zur
Fluchthelferin sie schmuggelt eine Feile
in die Justizvollzugsanstalt nein nicht
in der Hochzeitstorte und ein Jahr nach
der Heirat kann Norman Franz einen Stab
aus dem Gitter seines zellenfensters
fallen und während der Schichtwechsels
der Vollzugsbeamten an einem Regenrohr
aufs Dach klettern
auf der anderen Seite seid er sich mit
Bettlaken ab draußen erwartet ihn Sandra
mit einem Wagen und gefälschten Papieren
irre das klingt schon wieder nach einem
Gangsterfilm oder Bonnie und Clyde und
so aber die Realität hat absolut nichts
romantisch ist das sind keine Helden die
dem Gesetz ein Schnippchen schlagen
franz hat schon zwei Menschen auf
unfassbar brutale Weise ermordet und nur
zwei Wochen nach dem Ausbruch wird er
wieder zeigen was er ist ein eiskalter
Killer ohne Skrupel und Gewissen die
Flucht für die beiden nach Thüringen
hier überfallen sie zunächst ein paar
kioskel doch das Geld wird knapp Franz
will mehr am 20 März 1997 ist ein
Geldbote mit einer Geldkassette auf dem
Weg zu einer Filiale der Dresdner Bank
in Weimar
Norman Volker Franz nähert sich dem
ahnungslosen Mann sieht eine Waffe und
schießt sofort der 54-Jährige stirbt am
hellichten Tag vor dem Eingang der Bank
[Musik]
das ist so krass einfach so ein Leben
ausgelöscht er macht nicht mal den
Versuch das Geld zu rauben ohne zu töten
sondern das ist ja sein ganzer Plan
hingehen ein unschuldigen Menschen töten
und wegrennen
Franz reißt die Geldkassette an sich und
fliegt mit seiner Frau die vor der Bank
Wache gehalten hat zu Fuß das Paar
erbeutet 10.000 Mark ungefähr 5000 Euro
nicht genug für Normen Volker Franz am
21 Juli desselben Jahres verladen zwei
Geldboten die wocheneinnahmen eines
Metro Markt sind heißen bei Halle in
ihren Panzerwagen Franz schießt ihnen in
den Kopf ohne Vorwarnung ohne Zögern
ohne jede menschliche Regung
die beiden geldbooten haben keine Chance
sie werden nur 48 und 49 Jahre alt einer
von ihnen hat einen kleinen Sohn der
seinen Vater nie wieder sehen wird
Sandra Franz wartet im Fluchtwagen auf
ihren Mann den Mörder mit einer Beute
von
487.000 D-Mark flieht das verbrecherpaar
nach Albufeira einer Stadt an der
Algarve in Portugal und dort beginnen
Sie einen ganz normales Leben besser
gesagt etwas das aussieht wie ein
normales Leben unter den Namen Carsten
Müller und Michael stüfer gibt sich
Franz als Immobilienmakler aus noch im
selben Jahr 1997 bekommen sie einen Sohn
Mike es gibt Fotos von Norman Franz mit
seinem Sohn eigentlich echt süße Bilder
und stolzer Vater der mit leichtem
Lächeln in die Kamera blickt ein Baby
auf seiner Schulter die winzigen Füßlein
an den Wagen des Vaters und die winzigen
Hände in seinen Händen
in denselben Händen die den Ring von der
Handgranate gezogen und den Abzug der
Pistole betätigt haben an denen das Blut
von fünf Menschen klebt also wenn man
darüber nachdenkt ist das so was von
creepy
1999 findet die scheinbare Idylle ein
yes Ende sein Auto wird Franz zum
Verhängnis der BMW ist nicht
ordnungsgemäß angemeldet das fällt bei
einer Kontrolle auf als Beamte der
portugiesischen Polizei das Kennzeichen
überprüfen sehen sie dass der Wagen
unter einem Decknamen gekauft wurde den
der europaweit gesuchte Mörder Norman
Volker Franz häufig benutzt hat der
Mörder und seine Komplizin werden
verhaftet sie leisten keinen Widerstand
damit endet Norman Volker Franz
kriminelle Karriere hä stop hatten wir
den Satz nicht schon mal also glaubt
oder glaubt sie nicht aber besser ihr
glaubt es Norman Franz kann wieder
fliehen am 28 Juli 1999 entkommt er
nicht aus irgendeinem kleinen Provinz
Knast sondern aus dem Zentralgefängnis
in Lissabon diesmal ist das keine Pfeile
sondern eine Säge mit der er den
gitterstä und genau wie zwei Jahre zuvor
in Deutschland seit er sich an
zusammengeknoteten Laken ab der älteste
Trick aus der Mottenkiste und dieser Typ
zieht ihn gleich zwei Mal durch
unfassbar Sandra Franz sitzt unterdessen
im Frauengefängnis ihrem Mann ist es
gelungen zu ihr Kontakt aufzunehmen er
will auch sie befreien doch Sandra lehnt
ab sie will nicht mehr fliehen sie will
nicht mehr an der Seite eines Mörders
leben will nicht mehr seine Komplizin
sein nach einem weiteren Jahr in
portugiesischer Haft wird sie nach
Deutschland überstellt dort verurteilt
sie ein Gericht in Halle zu einer
Jugendstrafe von sechs Jahren und drei
Monaten
Sandra bereut und lässt sich scheiden
als sie heirateten saß er hinter Gittern
sie war frei jetzt sitzt sie im
Gefängnis und er ist draußen also frei
naja zumindest so frei man sein kann
wenn weltweit nach einem gefahrendet
wird aber bis heute ist Norman Franz auf
der Flucht bis heute sind im Zielfahnder
auf den Fersen und fest davon überzeugt
einen der gefährlichsten und
skrupellosesten Verbrecher der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland eines Tages
zu fassen wenn er überhaupt noch lebt
bis heute führen alle Spuren ins Lehrer
man vermutet ihnen Portugal in Marokko
oder auf Curacao auf Hinweise die zu
seiner Ergreifung führen sind mehr als
100.000 € Belohnung ausgesetzt da sich
sein Aussehen in den letzten Jahren
sicher stark verändert hat setzen die
fahrende auf eine stimmprobe einen
kurzen Ausschnitt eines
Telefongespräches das Norman Volker
Franz in Haft führte
gesprochen ne also der ist super auf
jeden Fall und ich Ende der Woche ich
bin jetzt
da wird dann
kriegen ob ich
ausgeliefert werden oder nicht ich weiß
nicht ob das endgültig ist auf jeden
Fall da findet so vor links statt
Ende der Woche war nicht von genau also
ich weiß noch nicht ob das die
endgültige auf jeden Fall ist das schon
mal so eine Verhandlung so warum es
darum geht
mit dem bekannten ruhig und ja und wenn
er das erledigt hast ich habe gerade
Ehefrau angerufenweise von dem Mann ja
ja ja und die war nicht da aber ich habe
im Büro angerufen der ist jetzt
unterwegs es ist nach allem was wir
erzählt haben eigentlich völlig
überflüssig das zu erwähnen aber
wenn ihr glaubt irgendwo auf der Welt
diese Stimme zu hören oder Normen Franz
zu sehen dann wendet euch bitte an die
Polizei vor Ort oder das
Landeskriminalamt Nordrhein-Westfalen
und haltet auf jeden Fall Abstand
sprecht ihn nicht an ja wahnsinn dass
dieser Typ noch frei rumläuft und das
ist bisher nicht gelungen ist in Ding
fest zu machen da kann man nur hoffen
dass Ihnen irgendjemand erkennt und dass
er endlich seine gerechte Strafe erhält
und hinter Gitter kommt auf jeden und
kleiner Tipp von mir vielleicht lässt
man dann in Zukunft die Bettlaken in der
Zelle weg
[Musik]
das war's für heute von uns um die
Geschichte von Norman Volker Franz zu
erzählen haben wir uns die Doppelfolge
von Achtung Fahndung von Bild TV zu
diesem Fall angeschaut weitere Infos und
Details haben wir bei Bild Stern und
Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst gefunden vielen
Dank fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten
mal eure Toni und
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Heyer Script und Postproduktion
[Musik]